um farron cousins during my break
talked about this and i want to talk a
little bit more about it
because this is now an actual
broadcaster
vocal anti-vaccine broadcaster dick
farrell
has died from covid19 complications okay
this was uh about a week ago i was away
when it took place
friends say dick farrell encouraged them
to get the vaccine after he was infected
so this is out of florida former south
florida talk show host dick farrell
known and beloved by fans for his
over-the-top right-wing opinions
has died from complications from covid19
on facebook farrell advocated against
getting the coronavirus vaccine and was
skeptical of dr anthony fauci chief of
the u.s national okay nih
and his recommendations concerning the
coronavirus friends say after
contracting the virus he changed his
point of view
kovit took one of my best friends rest
in peace dick farrell he is the reason i
took the shot he texted me and told me
get it he told me this virus is no joke
and he said i wish i had gotten it
that's farrell's close friend amy lee
hare
on her facebook page she said to wptv i
was one of the people like him who just
didn't trust the vaccine i trusted my
immune system i just became more afraid
of getting coveted 19 than i was of any
possible side effects of the vaccine i'm
glad i got vaccinated
that's a good thing
um and you know when we talk about
senseless death
there's a lot of different things that
we could mean we could mean that it was
avoidable
that's one thing when we say senseless
death we could be this was easily
avoidable it made no sense
sometimes by senseless death we mean it
was a death that accomplished nothing so
if
the military is waging some battle that
is a pointless battle that win lose it's
relevant it doesn't do it it helps no
one and then someone dies we would say
it was a senseless death because the
death didn't even contribute anything to
a worthwhile cause so senseless death
can mean a number of different things
if
we are going to have these anti-vaxx
people
and some of them are going to die
are we better off if they are prominent
and have a platform and then it gets out
that hey this person that you might have
heard of this person you listen to they
now are saying get the vaccine does it
reduce the senselessness of the death i
think to some degree it does
former market general manager for cbs
radio west palm beach lee strasser
remembers farrell he was flamboyant
outrageous willing to take on any and
all comers loved to engage with local
politicians pulled no point punches was
he right all the time no
but he was right all the time meaning
right wing especially if you asked him
did he stay out of trouble not always
was he great with clients yes was he a
pleasure in the building absolutely was
he loyal unquestionably was he skilled
yes sir his passing is a big loss
he was a kind-hearted person
etc etc so um
a straight-up anti-vaxxer a straight-up
anti-vaxxer now saying
go and get yourself the vaccine
um this is not a problem that's gonna go
away anytime soon
and particularly i don't want to get
ahead of myself but particularly as it
looks like
at the eight month mark of your
vaccination it will be recommended to
get a third dose what the jnj vaccine
recipients will be instructed to do we
don't yet know but for those who got the
two dose vaccines pfizer or moderna with
a third dose likely coming
this is going to be
another opportunity to have
significantly more protection and it's
going to be another opportunity for
these people to go
they just want to keep vaccine and
vaccine in order to
control us or microchip or whatever the
case may be
so as bad as it's been unfortunately
when the third dose recommendations go
sort of widespread and that could be
anywhere in the next 24 to 48 hours
there will unfortunately be even more of
this that we're going to have to contend
with
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read you have to check out
one of my favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist takes thousands of popular
nonfiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it i recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great stephen hawking this is a
book that i have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video